[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à vos poilus prêts partez dans votre
trésor en rond en france on vous parle
de la chandeleur évidemment on ne
pouvait pas passer à côté c'est l'un des
jours de l'année qu'on attend avec
impatience en tout cas les gourmands
alors est ce qu'il y a tout de même
quelques règles à respecter pour ne pas
rater sa pâte à crêpes tac je crois
qu'on fait un truc dans ce genre là
hop voilà prenez le petit instrument à
la halle esi
ate et regardez regardez regardez bon
j'ai pas trop moi je suis un peu nul
pour regarder la belle crête qu'on est
en train de vous préparer très
rapidement dressé c'est une terre et mer
voilà regarder on l'appelait
1954 raymond oliver réalise des crêpes
pour la première émission culinaire de
la télévision dany
et fois en vingt ans beaucoup parce que
ce chef d'un grand restaurant étoilé
parisien a ramené de son sud-ouest natal
sa conception disant généreuse de la
cuisine durant qui rendent comme par
contre récifal faire rentrer du liquide
[Musique]
on
l'a pas vous avez pensé quoi
d'accord d'ici on au pays de la cerise
meilleur appât et noyau non y'a pas la
cud non plus des ballons plus bas noyau
pas que parce que la cerise ça se paye
avec la que voilà et mon grand père
disait c'est déjà pas facile avec la
main ouais du rhum de la liqueur danis
et ce n'est pas tout alors je vais la
détente c'est à dire l'allongé avec la
bière
nous sommes presque pas tout à fait une
fois encore en maintenant un tout petit
et pour finir encore une petite rasade
pardon c'est si la route est encombrée
dollars un peu d'essence enfin une femme
classe comme toi en plus cécile à
d'euros mon petit retouvera satisfaction
ça veut dire que j'ai bien mangé quand
tu viens vraiment sur un bateau à
traverser les océans l'arabe il ya
vraiment pas de nourriture tu peux
vraiment pas très content hub wath on
urine parce que le dessalinisateur tombe
en panne tu dois vraiment avoir déjà bu
son urine dans l'atlantique nord oui
parce que l'ordinateur est tombé en
panne pendant cinq jours j'ai essayé de
réparer et la meilleure solution et que
c'était mort je ne crois pas si mais tu
as dit que tu voulais partir a
donc écarté votre bien formés puis
rejoints sur moi pour habitude
allez vas-y
dans la maison trop loin pour moi voilà
il est l'autre la voix la bible mais non
si on est tout seul on est foutu ah bah
oui mais normalement à la mer pour
éviter d'y aller tout seul je vous dit
ah ben oui on est foutu ah bah oui on
est foutu un avion de la british airways
est passé tout près la catastrophe lundi
regardait alors qu'il s'apprête à
atterrir sur l'aéroport londonien 10 rue
une violente rafale
déstabilise la paille
au moloko et vous voyez je vais le
pilote renonce donc à se poser voilà
imageurs et heureusement plus de peur
que de mal ça va pas
sa tâche est là mais il y avait renoncé
sur le groupe n'a pas extrême droite
sature l'espace il voulait que je prends
vous venez sur un plateau bosser un peu
c'est un petit conseil que je vous
redonne sa tête parce que j'ai bossé
j'allais faire le procès ou non mais
j'ai aussi cyril hanouna prochaine fois
pour la réponse est un peu et vous
entendez par là que vous soutenez jean
luc mélenchon est le seul boulot et
c'est celui l'extrême droite a largement
la parole aux idées mais la france est
aussi dit aussi je suis un guignol qui
est là pour faire du show je me moque
des témoins ce que je veux c'est faire
du fric de l'audimat et c'est maintenant
que c'est dit vous avez vu que je les
dis honnêtement monsieur português lyon
je vous repose la question speed auto
services réd il m'appelait monsieur
porte camion je vous êtes c'est pas
votre ne pas citer mon nom ben monsieur
cohen était cité mon nom je porte
plainte vais pas le premier vous avez
abeilles ne pouvait porter par monsieur
allez-y c'est pas mon nom tuée donnant
l'espoir s'atténue qu'en décembre face à
l'embarras des
déchets mais s'il vous plaît en blanc au
sujet du double non non non je vais te
finir avec sa fille l'a expliqué à lyon
puis chaque bien que vous dire je t'aime
bien est oui mais moi je suis là aussi
pour vous chez taïfu syrie et le groupe
d'âge en général et hp
moi j'étais poser tranquille en train de
balancer mes jambes c'est eux qui m'ont
en attendre plus de mon silence avec moi
même j'ai pas me laisser pour quelque
chose que j'avais a fait les jo jacques
bourdin et votre mari il est percuté par
la sphère de georges jacques bourdin qui
a été écarté de l'antenne de bfm je vous
ai entendu chez léa salamé avec et très
émouvant d'ailleurs de vous écouter et
très fort vous avez dit ce soir là sur
[Musique]
comment vous vivez cette situation qui
est quand même extrêmement et vous la
vivra par un livre mal monsieur comment
dont c'est la dernière fois que je vous
réponds déposer déposer les sharks tort
ok vous ne citez pas mon nom mais
pourquoi
parce que je veux pas que c'était mon
nom vous partez de discrédit sur toute
ma famille ils ont déjà eu des problèmes
comme ça vous ne citez pas mon nom alors
que
vous ne citez pas mon nom moi je suis
obligé d'être dans les médias
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai ce livre
et
vous entendez mon émotion je je je sais
pas si je continuerai à écrire des
livres je sais pas si je continuerai les
dans les médias parce qu'il ya trop
justement là on peut parler de n 2 n 2 n
et ça personne ne le méritent
personne non je tombe d'accord de tout
ce qui vous plaît ne marche pas caballé
par pur intérêt ce n'est plus que la rue
d'aujourd'hui qui l'emportent et les
hommes devraient être faits d'autres
sortes mais c'est vrai que ça marche bon
après c'est compliqué parce que cela
lexandre à marche pas tellement en rade
mais quand même mais c'est vrai que
c'est une parole tellement forte forte
que voilà la marche
ouais j'aime bien quand vous rapide du
molière mon père a eu un cancer oui mais
oui j'ai eu mon frère s'est fait écraser
par une voiture monsieur ma mère tu es
mort d'alzheimer vous voulez qu'on fasse
un concours de misère non alors voila
mon père large c'est votre
mais tu es passé à côté ok top top
niveau j'ai adoré ce moment vraiment y'a
aucun sarcasme dans cette voie
[Musique]
joie bonheur et coquelicots vous
garantis que si vous dites à cette
personne il ya un logement dans les
bouges à bâle ira dans les vosges parce
que les vosges c'est bien
rien
sympa on embrasse les vosgiens qui nous
regardent le maroc je sais pas si elle
comprend ça là bas mais c'est pas
provençal mais ça fait partie la
provence sur six est une région
cosmopolite tanit le connaissais pas ce
mot cosmopolite n ont toujours pas non
c'est une région cosmopolite
vous nous avez fait peur l'espace d'un
instant
aux propos voilà ça s'appelle merci
françois
une fin ou venir merci